good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the University of Southern
California and I'd like to welcome you
all to the big data to knowledge guide
to the fundamentals of data science
today march 30th 2018 we are delighted
to have dr. Curtis Hutton Hauer from
Harvard University's Chan School of
Public Health to discuss molecular data
and the microbiome dr. Hutton Hauer is
an associate professor of computational
biology and bioinformatics at Harvard's
Chan School of Public Health and he's an
associate member at the Broad Institute
he was an analysis lead on the NIH s
human microbiome project and he
currently leads the human microbiome
bioactives resource where his lab
focuses on computational methods for
functional analysis of microbial
communities and the micro and microbiome
epidemiology were absolutely delighted
to have him presenting his work today
again on the topic of molecular data and
the microbiome during his presentation I
encourage our audience members to submit
any questions that you may have for dr.
Hutton Hauer by using the little
questions submission facility as part of
the go-to webinar a little panel I'll
usually on the right-hand side of your
screen and without further ado I'd like
to turn this over to dr. Hutton Howard
to begin his presentation thank you so
much Curtis for presenting today
excellent likewise thanks Jack everyone
there who organizes it everyone who's
attending I'm very pleased that the
technology can can bring such a great
group of people together
hopefully I'm audible at this point you
are excellent okay well with that as
Jack said and the very kind introduction
the group here works on microbial
community and human microbiome studies
with a computational focus and this of
course addresses questions of how the
collection of microbes we carry in and
on our bodies bacteria fungi viruses
other types of microbes affect our
health outcomes so I'll speak today both
about some of the ways in which this
affects Public Health and of the
accompany
computation and data science challenges
and it's easy to forget after that the
past few years worth of interest in the
microbiome that it's actually been
studied for quite a long time some of
the earliest microscopy done by van
Leeuwenhoek
actually resulted in imaging of his own
human microbiome with microbes isolated
from to the oral microbial community as
somebody who sits at a school of public
health though perhaps some of the more
urgent reason to study the microbiome is
the rise in chronic non-pathogenic but
immune linked disease over the past
several decades
so collections of diseases like type 1
diabetes or inflammatory bowel disease
which I'll speak about today that are
affected by our immune systems
interaction with our typical microbial
environment but which are not caused by
a specific pathogen like like an
infectious disease and the microbiome
has now been linked to a really
surprising range of chronic disease not
just gut centered conditions like
inflammatory bowel disease but systemic
worm like type 1 diabetes rheumatoid
arthritis reason behavioral conditions
like autism and it's easy to imagine
over the past say 75 years the range of
environmental exposures that have
changed how we have that have changed
the interaction between our immune
system and our microbes that we evolved
with for millions of preceding years
these include some obvious things like
diet or the environment that surrounds
us where we live and work
antimicrobial exposures that have
evolved a great deal since the 1950s but
there's also some less obvious ones like
certainly probiotics other
pharmaceutical exposures but even how
we're born how we age or things like our
daily stress levels that can modify how
our immune system interacts with with
our natural microbes so the microbiome
provides a high dimensional readout of
human health and of molecular activity
in much the same way that's a human
genetics or human gene expression can
this can be used to do things like
predict disease risk or disease
prognosis but unlike these other
readouts the microbiome has a potential
to be modified so certainly antibiotics
are a huge modification and there's
interest in other types of more targeted
modification of the microbiome to not
just read out but restore health once we
figure out the right ways in which to do
it
so that's one of the main goals of our
research and one of the main tools
that's used by us and of the entire
microbiome research community is
high-throughput sequencing and again
this is really aid in the past several
years renaissance in microbial community
studies to give a quick overview of how
sequencing is used as one of the
molecular tools for microbial community
studies any such study be it that you
guys the human microbiome or otherwise
starts with typically a culture
independent sample of microbes and laces
the cells breaks them open to extract
nucleotides DNA or increasingly RNA to
understand microbial transcription as
well as microbial genomes there are two
common types of sequencing that are used
for microbial community studies the
first of which I'll refer to as amplicon
sequencing relies on PCR to amplify a
single marker gene from it within this
entire pool of microbial DNA this is
most commonly regions of the conserved
16s RNA gene so this is a a gene that's
carried by essentially all bacteria
specifically and by amplifying only
variants of that one gene each variant
each sequencing Reed can be used to
detect variants at that one position
it's a very cost-effective and efficient
way to use sequencing to study microbial
communities each Reed just looks at
changes within this one gene and those
small changes can be classified back to
reference databases that tell us where
they came from which organism they came
from so this gives us essentially a
microbial census in which each sample
generates a list of microbes and how
many reads were classified to them so it
counts how much or what percentage of
each text on each organism is detected
per sample an alternative to amplicon or
16
that sequencing as it's called is
metagenomic sequencing of DNA or meta
transcriptomic sequencing of RNA in
which you just plain sequence everything
so very much like shotgun sequencing of
individual genomes like the human genome
this type of metagenomic or meta
transcriptomic sequencing generates a
pile of short reads but rather than
being from a single organism through
derive from tens or hundreds or
sometimes thousands of different
organisms within a community so this can
be used to get a more complete picture
of an underlying microbial community at
the cost of some more computational and
data science complexity the types of
information you can then derive from
this include not just quantifying which
bugs are there but figuring out what
genes they might be carrying putting to
some degree those genes back together
into microbial genomes figuring out what
kinds of metabolism or biochemistry is
contained within those genomes or
zooming way in and looking at microbial
genetics and very precise variants
within those microbial communities again
kind of like you would for for human
genetics population study so these two
complimentary types of sequencing are
some of the main tools used to generate
data about microbial communities in the
human microbiome and they're
increasingly accompanied by a collection
of other molecular data types that can
be derived from microbiome samples when
I say sample here don't think too hard
about what that might be we'll we'll get
into the the guts of the situation
literally in a few slides
between now and then though in addition
to sequencing data microbial communities
can be studied in a number of ways
briefly summarized here as cellular data
so including things like direct
visualization through high-throughput
microscopy or sometimes culture based
method actually growing organisms from a
sample rather than treating its culture
independently or using cell sorting
methods such as flow cytometry that
directly counts which cells are there in
addition to these cell focused methods
other types of biomolecular data
typically derived from microbial
communities include mass spec results
such as
metabolomic or proteomics quantification
and these can then accompany the two
types of amplicon or method genome and
meta transcriptome sequencing described
on that the previous slide the types of
information that one can get out of
these sequencing data in particular
include things like taxonomic profiling
in other words figuring out which bugs
are there like we described for amplicon
sequencing or there are ways to zoom in
on specific of variants within amplicons
to identifying not just which organisms
but which exact strain which exact type
of each microbe is present in the
community these are both possible from
amplicon sequencing which again looks at
just one gene one locus or one the
source of variation in a microbial
community method genomes and meta
transcriptomes
can generate additional complimentary
data such as functional profiling which
again quantifies the genes or pathways
present in a collection of communities
or in addition to taxonomic profiling
and variant applet typing like amplicon
data can generate message enums can
provide assemblies so either whole or
sometimes partial microbial genomes
derived directly from culture
independent communities and these
genomes can also tell you about which
bugs biochemistry or strain variation or
present so finally from all of these
different data types
these can be they can be carried
downstream for integration different
types of statistics or visualization and
these include things like molecular
epidemiology associating changes in the
microbiome with Co various health
outcomes disease status environmental
exposures further analyses can be
performed focusing on molecular biology
or biochemistry what pathways or
microbes using to generate small
molecules that affect our guts or our
systemic health copy T our comparative
genomics or phylogenetics so zooming in
on which streams are present how they
evolve how things like antibiotics might
affect
microbial selection in the entire
microbiome or finally things like
systems biology or biophysical models
looking at the dynamics of community
change using combinations of these data
so touch on several of these different
data analysis types from multiple
different types of microbiome data today
using mainly examples from the human
microbiome project this will include
both what is commonly referred to as a
human microbiome project or HMP now
which I'll refer to as HMT one I'm
having wrapped up a few years ago now so
the HMP one was an NIH funded project to
define a baseline of normal human
microbial variation unlike our genomes
which are 99.9 percent plus similar from
person to person and the last few
variants obviously matter quite a bit
our microbiome is rarely overlapped by
more than 10% from person to person
there's a huge amount of normal baseline
variation in what microbes we carry so
several years ago now the hmp1 set out
in a quote healthy or baseline
population to define the bounds of this
normal variation we're really to just
understand who's there which microbes
are present in what configuration in the
absence of perturbation term disease so
after wrapping up in 2012 the hmp1
provided sort of a baseline catalog to
contextualise disease associated
variation in the microbiome those were
further studied by the HMP - or
integrative HMP which is just recently
wrapping up and this had more of a
functional mandate from the NIH to
analyze the biology and specifically
functional molecular biology of both the
microbiome and host interactions
dynamically over time and with a focus
on disease in addition to this quote
healthy baseline so the HMP - consisted
of three main projects with three
specific disease targets i'll speak
today about our work in inflammatory
bowel disease and this project is
accompanied by two others in the HMP
- on pregnancy and preterm birth at
Virginia Commonwealth and type-2
diabetes and obesity at Stanford and
Jackson labs as you'll see in several
slides all of these projects data are
available through a data Coordination
Center run at the University of Maryland
so to speak a little bit too
inflammatory bowel disease as an
environment in which to study the
microbiome it's been a model for
different types of gut microbial
dysbiosis for a surprisingly long period
of time so even before the recent burst
of work in human microbiome studies you
can go back many decades and find
language in publications that
surprisingly modern with respect to
describing how the gut microbiome is
perturbed in a complex way in
inflammatory bowel disease and so IBD
became a model for microbiome studies
over the course again of several decades
starting in the 1940s and 1950s when the
disease was observed to be sometimes
responsive to antibiotic treatment but
without a single base relatable or
cultural pathogen that seemed to be
causative this continued over the
subsequent few decades as other types of
treatments were introduced five AFA is
in the saladin that are still common
treatments for inflammatory bowel
diseases which affect gut microbes
without being explicitly antimicrobial
but also without targeting a single
causative pathogen and then finally in
the 1970s and 80s as genetically
modified mice were introduced several of
them recapitulate IBD like phenotypes
with a disruptive gut microbiome so
again without a single organism that
could be blamed for this this disease
and then in the past decade or so as
sequencing has become such a common tool
to better understand how the gut
microbiome is disrupted in IBD
things progressed fairly rapidly from
early observations of reduced diversity
or dysbiosis
so just lacking the typical range of
microbes found in the gut through
identifying which organisms become more
or less abundant during IBD to finally
starting to differentiate how these
affect the mean subsets of inflammatory
bowel disease so these include things
like ulcerative colitis Crohn's disease
and you'll see some more details about
these on the next few slides so in terms
of how these data can be analyzed you
can again compare a lot about these sort
of complex disruptions in the microbiome
to complex human genetics so if you
think about infectious disease or
Mendelian human genetic disease these
are both due to a single cause of large
effect so a genetic disorder like cystic
fibrosis really comes from a single
locus and that causes most of the
disease affect the microbial side a
parallel would be a pathogen so
something like color that's really
caused by a single organism of large
effect so there's been a great deal of
work on complex human genetics in the
past two decades and yet include traits
and diseases that are caused not by one
locus of large effect but by the
synergistic effect that many genes or
pathway is working together and this
used to be the case in complex microbial
dysbiosis as well in which there's not a
single pathogen but a functional
consequence of many bugs or the normal
ecology of the gut or other parts of the
human microbiome becoming disrupted so
to better understand these disruptions
in inflammatory bowel disease during the
HMP 2 we worked with ramnik savior's
group at the road to put together a
cohort of just over a hundred
individuals who were followed for one
year each consisting about half of
Crohn's disease patients 1/4 of
ulcerative colitis patients and about
1/4 of non IBD controls the cohort was
recruited from a series of different
clinical centers roughly half adult and
half pediatric and these very generous
patients contributed stool samples every
two years or sorry every two weeks for
one year these are our primary sample
type with which to study the gut
microbiome in addition to colon biopsies
collected at enrollment and blood draws
collected roughly quarterly so from
these three different sample types we're
able to get a whole set of different
data much of the stool data's still
derived data
out to describe the microbiome mainly
using sequencing metagenomics and meta
transcriptomics in addition to a series
of other molecular datatypes
metabolomics and proteomics from mass
spec like i mentioned earlier a subset
of virally targeted sequencing and then
some host targeted measures from the
stool samples including cow protectin
which is a protein measure of gut
inflammation or biopsies and blood draws
provided mostly human focused data some
of which was again sequencing including
exome sequencing of the human hosts
epigenetic bisulfate sequencing of
methylation both right in the gut from
the bio cheese and in circulating blood
and then a couple of other non
sequencing data types there including
serology from the blood so antibody
markers in circulating blood and finally
16s or amplicons sequencing of microbes
again directly in the gut from these
biopsy samples so you can see from these
numbers down the side there are several
thousand samples touching many different
data types describing as mandated both
microbial and host changes over time
during IBD to give an overview of how
this broke down over both time and up
individuals within the populations for
each genotype Crohn's disease ulcerative
colitis and our control individuals we
had a subpopulation of a very densely
sampled so generating data from almost
every sample provided over the course of
the year and then subpopulations that
were targeted to specific aligned time
points what this allowed us to do is
generate multi-omics data to integrate
as many of these different data types as
possible over time so this complicated
subway diagram here is essentially a
Venn diagram listing the overlap between
these different data types anchored off
of metagenomic sequencing for which we
had a total of just under 1700 samples
and most of these overlapped with one or
more other molecular data types so I
won't go through the details here but
for example essentially
all of the meta transcriptome sequencing
sequence data sets were drawn from the
same samples as a mecha genome
essentially all of the meta proteomics
and metabolomics samples were also drawn
from underlying metagenomes and so forth
and so forth down to roughly 300 samples
for which we have all six of these
microbially targeted data types from the
same samples time points and individuals
so this gives us an opportunity to look
at how each measurement of the
microbiome changes over time and how
they integrate with each other cross
sectionally and dynamically so all of
these data are being made available as
they're generated essentially all of
them are online currently at the IBD
multi-omics database or IBD MDD portal
in addition to the main HMP data
coordinating center that I mentioned
earlier the IVD MVP has a little more
focused information for our project in
particular including all of the
protocols that we used for sample
collection and data generation so if
you're interested in doing your own
study and really want to collect
thousands of small samples there's a
protocol describing how we did that
using a home based kit that could be
dropped in the mail and shipped in and
then of course all the raw and processed
data are being made available on the IBD
MDB as well along with the clinical
metadata describing these patients their
medical histories their medication and
how these change over the course of a
year to show a few first looks at how
we've been integrating some of these
different molecular data types in the
HMP - I'll show an example first of work
comparing the gut meta-genome to the gut
meta transcriptome so in other words the
collection of DNA that's present in in
microbes during IBD and the collection
of RNA or their transcriptional activity
in the gut so this is an example from
one pathway an acetyl glucosamine
degradation which is a type of mucus
metabolism carried out by a subset of
gut microbes each column here represents
the distribution of which organisms are
express
thing transcriptionally this pathway
across a subset of one of our pilot
datasets within the HMP - so there's a
smaller number of samples here obviously
in almost every individual factory as
well got us a specific species that's
common in the gut is uniquely
responsible for this type of mucus
metabolism and when we look at this not
just cross sectionally but
longitudinally that's true within most
subjects over time as well so when we
take one patients for time points that
we have in this pilot data set at each
time point factory is Vulcanus is both
the only organism carrying this pathway
in its genome and the only organism
transcribe essentially the only organism
transcribing it so this is likely the
bug responsible for this particular
portion of mucus metabolism in the gut
for this individual but that's not true
for all patients so if we go to another
individual with more active disease
factory as well goddess is typically the
dominant organism carrying this pathway
in its DNA but other organisms take over
that functionality at different points
in time
so even very rare organisms can become
responsible for this type of
biochemistry transiently
so in the second time point a different
factories Ailanthus Aldens has taken
over a plurality of the pathway in the
third time point factories messily
enza's have taken over and so forth as
this patient goes through more active
changes in their their alter to colitis
status the organisms carrying this
pathway don't change but the organism is
carrying out this activity the organism
is transcribing this particular mucus
metabolism pathway change from time
point of time point so this could
reflect aspect of instability in the gut
microbiome corresponding to disease
activity that's not necessarily visible
in just measuring the DNA but which can
be seen in which bugs are carrying out a
pathway transcriptome acclaim this seems
to be a general principle within the gut
not just true in disease activity but
even at baseline if we
pair which organisms can contribute all
pathways to which organisms are actively
transcribing them so here on the y-axis
each point represents one pathway just
like those overall plot does boil down
to a single point on the y-axis is the
diversity of how many organisms can
contribute a pathway on the x-axis as
the diversity of how many organisms are
transcribing that pathway everything is
above the diagonal which is good you
expect more bugs to carry a pathway than
to activate it at any given time excuse
me
and what's interesting here is that in
the lower left are the more unique
pathways those that are only carried by
a few bugs if you look at the coloring
this corresponds to how actively
transcribed that pathway is these tend
to light up so the more unique a
functionality is the more it tends to be
over expressed another example of this
in different organism is mcdonough
Genesis this is a pathway that's really
only present in a very few bugs the
archaea in the gut and it can be over
expressed by as much as a hundredfold
so those few bugs that can perform that
specific biochemistry tend to work
really hard at it they're carrying out
their particular function a particular
niche in the gut we can perform this
type of multi-omics data comparison for
other combinations of molecular data in
the microbiome as well so that example
compared metagenomes to meta
transcriptomes in one of our pilot data
sets we can do something similar
comparing metagenomes to metabolomics is
of different small molecules in our in
the gotten of the stool samples from ehm
v2 so this is a slightly different pilot
data set again not including the full
final sample set but here we've measured
in addition to metagenomes
the abundances of about four or five
hundred identified compounds and several
thousand unidentified compounds and
collaboration cleric wishes proof about
the Broad Institute so this plot
summarizes the classes
a number of each class of compounds that
are individually enriched or depleted in
Crohn's disease and ulcerative colitis
very much like the microbial enrichment
or depletions in IBD that I mentioned
earlier the way things get more
interesting is when we start integrating
these small molecule chemical changes
with the microbial changes this plot
shows the correlation of organisms that
are either enriched or depleted during
inflammatory bowel disease with small
molecules chemicals that are enriched in
the gut or depleted during inflammatory
bowel disease so each cell in the
keynote correlates a bug with a compound
and this is after correcting for a
variety of Co various so things like
subject age antibiotic exposure or even
disease activity itself so even though
these are bugs and compounds that are
disrupted in disease we've tried to
regress out as much of that effect as we
can so we can instead look at microbial
biochemical covariation what this then
means when a bug in us or what it
suggests when a bug in a small molecule
covary this strongly across the
population is that there might be
something mechanistic going on this
could be a compound that a positively
correlated organism generates
biochemically or it could be a compound
that Co varies because this bug depends
on it as a nutrient or alternatively an
organism might ecologically interact
with another organism that generates or
generates or depends on this compound
when some of these Co variations are so
strong we find a lot of very striking
correlations between microbes and very
specific compounds some of these are so
strong that we can do some gazing into
the method genome to help explain
mechanistically why these these
observational correlations might be
happening an example of that will see an
example of that from Runa caucus Mavis
specifically in a few slides but it's
surprising how often these correlations
happen
or unintuitive reasons there's a lot of
themes that will come back to a couple
of times that there's a lot we don't
know about microbial biochemistry in the
wild in the gut and other parts of the
human microbiome so when we go looking
for known enzymes annotated microbial
genes that are known to generate or
metabolize specific compounds we find
very few cases in which we can correlate
a known enzyme with the compound that it
generates or consumes there are a few of
these examples with ethanolamine or
glutathione for example and the other
annotations of the enzymes responsible
for processing those compounds across
samples and in a variety of different
organisms but these are the exception
rather than the rule and if there are
micro biologists in the audience and you
look closely at this slide you can
actually guess why this might be
happening in as much as there's a lot of
green so the color here indicates which
organisms are contributing these enzymes
in each of the three phenotypes IBD
Crohn's disease ulcerative colitis and
controls and if you compare the
enrichment for these organisms to the
legend below you can see the green is
actually equal I which is one of the
best annotated organisms where we do
know quite a bit of biochemistry and we
can assign biochemical function to many
of its genes but there are very few
cases where we can find this specific of
information so far so even though we can
identify genes that covary with
compounds they may be completely
unattainable by OU chemistry left to
discover there we can just from a purely
computational or machine learning
perspective use those earn annotated
genes or compounds to ask questions
about IBD more broadly so for example
it's fairly easy to fairly well
differentiate the IBD gut from a
controlled microbiome so from non IBD or
quote healthy controls so using in this
case a random forest classifier but this
is true for essentially any
discriminative machine learning
algorithm
we can separate individuals with and
without IBD with fairly good accuracy
using either a measurement of which
chemicals are there a measurement of
which bugs are there or it's not on this
plot we can do the same to using a
measure of which genes are there the
classification test gets a little bit
harder when we differentiate subtypes of
IBD so for example separating ulcerative
colitis of Fermin crohn's disease
drops the accuracy a little bit but what
I think is interesting about this result
whether the machine learner can do
roughly as well whether it's learning
from chemicals or which organisms are
present in the microbiome or again not
not shown here but the same is true for
genes and pathways in the microbiome
which again points to the very tight
link between which bugs in which
biochemical DNA is present which enzymes
are present in the gut and the
metabolite pools that we observe through
metabolomic profiling of a gut
microbiome so finally to get to one more
specific example of this by zooming
further into that that room dukakis
Navis example i mentioned earlier we
have a third pilot data set from within
the HMT within the HMV to the values for
this example which compared specifically
the dense longer longitudinal time
courses across crohn's disease and are a
subset of the control subjects so in
taking a look at this longitudinal data
set but bravely Miranda the postdocs
work on this project did was ask
questions about the functionality of
microbes that were changing in IBD or in
Crohn's disease specifically over time
and one of the things that they found on
this that's been suggested by meta
genomic profiling earlier is that there
are more commonalities in the types of
biochemistry that gets perturbed during
IBD than in the specific organisms and
one example of this is the class of
facultative anaerobes or arrow tolerant
microbes in the gut tend to be enriched
in IBD and the causality for this could
go either way so this could either be a
option of more oxygen being present in
the guts during inflammation and
allowing these bugs to grow or these
bugs being pro-inflammatory and sort of
causing the inflammation and the IBD in
the first place
but you can see this enrichment for a
whole group of different organisms
either when comparing the Crohn's and
control individuals from within this HMV
to pilot data set or when comparing it
to other external gut microbiome data
sets including the healthy population in
the HMV one or another crohn's disease
study carried out at university of
pennsylvania individual organisms may
not show such a strong enrichment during
inflammation but the entire class of
arrow tolerant organisms does and you
can see this when we zoom into room
dukakis Navis is a representative of
this group of organisms
it's weakly enriched individually but
the overall functional or enrichment is
a lot more statistically significant
what's interesting about Runa caucus
Navis though is that one of the reasons
it's so hard to see this enrichment in
an individual organism is that it's not
the whole organism that seems to be
associated with inflammatory bowel
disease and inflammation in the
microbiome it's only certain strains of
room in a caucus Navis so what you're
looking at here is on each column is one
sample from either a Crohn's disease or
control individuals who did carry room
the caucus Mavis in their gut you can
see that a small number of control
individuals who are carrying room to
caucus Davis but there are about 200
genes that's what each row represents
that were only carried by the strains of
microbes the strains of room in a caucus
Navis present in the IVD gut and we can
put biochemical annotation on a small
set of these genes some of them deal
with error tolerance and oxidative
stress management others correspond to
more pathogen or paths of ions like
functions like adhesion or invasion and
others have really interesting metabolic
annotation like iron utilization but the
vast majority are again uh Nana cated
they
have good homology to other into other
well-characterized enzymes out in
reference databases so in as much as
I'll again come back to this a few times
it's a micro biological or biochemical
challenge to figure out what these genes
do but computation biologists I would
also frame it as a data management
challenge a lot of low-hanging fruit and
using slightly more intelligent
algorithms than just playing homology to
start getting an idea of what some of
the microbial dark matter but seem is
functionally significant in the
microbiome might be doing so it's not in
mind I'll send some of the rest of the
time on what you can think of as the
other HMV two or a second wave of
analysis carried out in the quote
healthy or baseline population of the
hmp1
so to help differentiate this population
or refer to examples from this study at
the HM T 1/2 so this is a set of
similarly flavored analyses carried out
on metagenomes
from the hmp1 healthy population and so
I introduced this briefly earlier but to
go into a little bit more detail of how
the hmp1 defined a baseline microbiome
this population included 300 quote
healthy subjects who were screened at
five different body areas for a fairly
high and specific degree of clinical
health so very few oral health oral
hygiene issues there was a specific BMI
range that had to be followed no skin
abrasions for example and this allowed
up to 18 different body sites to be
sampled not just the gut but a series of
nasal many different oral sites across
the mouth a few different skin sites
again stool representing the gut and a
series of different vaginal microbiome
samples and women the HMT 1 and 1 2
included three different visits to get a
little bit of longitudinal information
for this population as well and as well
as again metadata describing the
demographics and background and
environment of these individuals
so the initial set of information
published with the HMT one several years
ago focused mainly on the several
thousand amplicon symbols that were
analyzed across essentially all of these
samples that were collected for the hmp1
to more recently we just finished
analysis of about 2400 method genomes
across a subset of these individuals and
body sites but now spanning roughly all
three time points for all individuals
and the subset of six representative
body sites from the different areas so
I'll talk about some of the results from
that I think some of the interesting
data challenges here is certainly
wrangling this large a set of
meta-genome performing things like
quality control raw bioinformatics on
the cemented genomic sequencing data and
metagenomic assembly was greatly
facilitated by again owen White's team
at the data coordinating Center who are
doing this as part of the NIH data
Commons project in addition to the HMP
to what we could then get out of that is
not just more data than we had in the
hmp1
but a series of updated analyses
including very specific functional
profiling that we'll see in a few slides
very specific taxonomic profiling down
to the tracking of individual streams
and I'll describe some of the computing
behind that as well and then a few
things I won't have time for today
including non-bacterial profiling fungi
and viruses the updated assembly that I
mentioned gene catalogs it derived from
these assemblies and then a little bit
about the multiple time point in except
I will describe the analysis methods for
but to start with some of the easy views
of what this information can tell you as
to starting at a 30,000 foot view of the
overall human microbiome these meta
genomic profiles now show much the same
information that was available from the
amplicon data originally in the HMP one
in which many of the largest differences
in the human microbiome across the body
are derived from the body site itself
Buzz's care about their immediate a bio
chemical
microbes are essentially little bags of
biochemistry so when you ask what are
the biggest differences across the human
microbiome the first answer is the
immediate environment the body site is
that a collection of microbes likes to
live in so that means when we put these
2,400 metagenomes together most of the
variation that we can see at a high
level derives from this different body
sites from which the samples are derived
the gut is a very unique environment it
tends to carry a different microbial
ecology the same is true for skin the
vaginal microbiome sites were quite
similar to each other but distinct from
the other microbial environment sampled
here and that I mentioned there were
multiple different oral body sites which
you can see here in the kind of cool
colors and a continuum in which we can
actually help show some examples later
differentiate fairly specific locations
within the oral cavity such as the tooth
surface the cheek or the tongue which
were the three main oral body sites
studied here this is a very high-level
view in which each point represents a
sample and the distance between points
represents how dissimilar they are but
of course this is supported by very
detailed information underneath both her
simple listing which organisms are there
and their abundances and as we'll see in
a few slides differentiating those
organisms into specific streams as well
the first analysis I want to describe
using the information about these
taxonomic profiles though within
characterizing how they changed over
time is something new within the HM T
1/2 and uses what I think was an
interesting data analysis method for
this type of data specifically Gaussian
processes so you can think of a Gaussian
process as a probabilistic functional
regression so a way of fitting occur
probabilistically to a series of
measurements over time which is exactly
what we have here we have a series of
multiple time points measured for the
microbiome each measuring a collection
of organisms in different individuals
and in different body sets so we will
to ask how different organisms were
changing over time across the body
within the microbiome and Gaussian
processes gave us a way to do that by
decomposing each of these sets of
changes into a couple of specific
mechanisms so specifically we built a
set of Gaussian processes to model
microbial change as a combination of
staple enter individual differences so
bugs that are just always different
between people and their abundances
depend on who you are not what time it
is microbes is very steadily over time
and these are organisms that might for
example be responsive to long term
dietary perturbations or long term
medical pharmaceutical interventions so
things like antibiotics and then finally
since we have a series of technical
replicates we could differentiate
between microbes that change rapidly on
their own
biologically versus those that have
measurement error and have essentially
technical noise so you can think of this
as rapid change and this as a
measurement error so by hinting
probabilistically this hierarchical
gaussian process to our longitudinal
data we can describe each bug in terms
of these three properties of interest
does it differ stabili between
individuals
does it change slowly over time or does
it change rapidly over time so these
three locations and the plot I'm about
to show correspond to these three
temporal patterns state the stability
between individuals slow temporal change
and rapid temporal change and we can
then plot over this simplex each
organism or it turns out I won't show it
today you can do the same thing for
pathways within a particular body site
so here we broken down the gut
microbiome in the healthy population of
the hmp1 - based on these temporal
behaviors and you can immediately see
some consistency in what different
microbes are doing the Bacteroides which
are one of the dominant groups of bugs
in the gut tend to be stable within
individuals
or time some people will have won
factories and some people have a
different type of factories these blue
dots represent another major group of
organisms and Augusta Firmicutes and
they tend overall to show more slow
variation so this might include things
like diet responsiveness and then
finally a subset of more opportunistic
organisms like e.coli change rapidly
over time they can grow or die off or
grow again very quickly in response to a
changing environment so zooming in to a
slightly higher level of taxonomic
information we can profile not just
which organisms are present in the gut
microbiome but which strains of each
organism are present and a one quick one
slide summary of one of the
computational methods for doing this
relies on mapping the short reads within
a mento genome to a collection of pre
specified unique marker sequences for
each species so for this particular tool
called strain plan we take a collection
of reference sequence information we
identify the most unique sequences for
each species and then given a new method
genome we can map those short reads to
just these unique markers and call
snippet the variants within those
confidently identified markers this
allows for each species and each sample
the construction of a strain level
haplotype a set of variants unique to
the strain of that species in each
sample and these can then be visualized
in a number of different ways some of
which are exactly the same as you would
do for microbial genetics and a
collection of isolates by looking at the
follow Janee or divergence between
strains and different samples you can
associate these with phenotype so for
example if this is the Fulani of the
strains of one organism across many
different cut micro biomes this set of
strains is enriched for the cartoon red
phenotype and this set of strains is
enriched for the purple phenotype
equivalently you can show the same type
of information
again in an ordination like we saw
earlier but here each point represents
the strain of a particular species in
one meta-genome and distance between
points represents how diverged
genetically those strains are so using
that we can both Associates trains with
phenotype like I showed them at the
previous slide or ask some basic
biological questions about how strains
evolved in the human microbiome in the
first place so one of the ways in which
we did this was by comparing the genetic
diversity of organisms within each body
site to the diversity between body sites
some organisms like to specialize to a
particular biochemical environment and
essentially diverged into different
organisms across body sites whereas
other organisms transfer genetic
material more freely and are more
cosmopolitan and you can see this better
with some examples where if I take a
point that's right on this diagonal the
diversity of strep cell various between
and within body sites is roughly the
same so each point here represents one
strain of strep cell various from a
number of different body sites we can
see does a great deal of genetic
diversity but it doesn't really
segregate within any particular part of
the the oral cavities and so this is a
typically oral microbe a counter example
is something like homoplasy RN from
parent blends it which is up off the
diagonal here this organism has a
comparable amount of genetic diversity
but it started to differentiate into
groups of strains that are unique to
each of the three main oral sites so you
can actually find different types of HBR
in flow and a on the tooth surface
versus the cheek versus the tongue this
is the level of biochemical
specialization that some microbes in the
microbiome are able to attain you can
actually differentiate different
ecological strategies genetically across
very very nearby surfaces within the
oral cavity so finally I'll wrap up not
with methods for detecting poo there in
the microbiome but but a little but with
a little bit about functional profiling
understanding the biochemistry that we
can detect from meta-genome the meta
transcriptomes
so a quick one slide summary of one of
the methods we have to do that starts
with again a meta genome or meta
transcriptome and after detecting which
organisms are present in the sample
using the methods they described earlier
retrieve their reference sequences from
an underlying database so not just the
unique markers or the most specific
sequences but all genes or the pan
genome associated with each organism in
a community maps metagenomic or meta
transcriptomic reads to those genes
counts up hips and can thereby describe
which genes and which organisms are
carrying them in a community and then
finally for reads that do not map to
specific nucleotides
we carry out a more computationally
expensive translated search hits from
this process to a larger protein
database can still tell you something
about the biochemistry of what that gene
might be doing but not necessarily which
organism is carrying it so this gives a
functional profile of a microbial
community in which we can quantify very
much like you would for say a
transcriptome X or RNA seek the
abundance of each gene family in the
community in units that are basically
like our pecans or relative abundances
and these are broken down when possible
into the contributing organism for each
gene family or into a set of
unclassified organisms when we only know
that a protein level of the gene family
is there for the subset of these gene
families that are biochemically
characterized we can also put them back
together into pathways and do the same
thing to quantify and taxonomically
annotate the contributions of each
pathway to a community in addition to
the uncharacterized gene families so I'm
running a little low on time I'll move
quickly through the last few examples of
using this within the human microbiome
including things like finding human
specific pathways so pathways that are
carried microbially across many
different
biochemical environments on the body and
these speak to processes that are
enriched in hosts associated microbes so
things that the bugs have to do
somewhere in their ecology in order to
survive in association with a human
being and you can see what from this one
example of vitamin D metabolism on the
bottom here that across the body many
different organisms might carry out this
process but it seems to be necessary for
it to be carried out by some organism
within the community to form a stable
ecology and this is in addition of
course to body site or biochemical
specific processes that are carried out
by different bugs within a specific
environment so for example nitrate
reduction is always carried out by some
organism in the oral cavity that this
can again be a different organism from
person to person or mouth to mouth in
the stage so this type of functional
profiling gives us sort of a way of
linking ecology and biochemistry in the
microbiome by looking at the diversity
of organisms that can provide a pathway
both within an individual or between
individuals ranging from pathways that
are more or less core to the human
microbiome they must be present in every
individual in some environment sometimes
rarely these are provided by a specific
organism and that organism is the same
between individuals but more commonly
there's diversity in which organisms can
provide a particular type of
biochemistry so here's an example in
which only one organism per individual
tends to provide a pathway but that
organism can differ between individuals
and then finally more typically there
can be many different microbes per
individual that can carry out a
particular type of biochemistry and
often it's not even the same bugs per
individual so there can be diversity
both in which organisms per individual
provide a pathway and in how they change
between individuals so this leads us to
some of the challenges in microbial
community in human microbiome
analysis and data science which range
all the way from the very molecular
focus that I was just describing up to
higher-level questions of population
health and microbial interactions I
highlighted already a lot of the dark
matter or open questions around the
underlying biochemistry or cellular
biology that we can see in the
microbiome from these different types of
molecular data and of course many of
these affect translation and human
health as I mentioned the beginning the
microbiome provides not just a high
dimensional readout of human health but
also a potential point of intervention
once we know the right direction in
which to push it we can make changes to
a microbial community in a way that it
would be very difficult with human
genetics finally many of these human
health considerations have effects at
the population level as well so for
example early life antimicrobial or
probiotic exposures later then influence
microbiome acquisition or development
and thus later life allergic or atopic
phenotypes as well so all the tools that
I briefly mentioned today are available
online as part of the labs bio bakery
collection both of individual
open-source methods and a virtual image
that includes all of these pre-built and
documented and set up within a single
environment so if you're interested in
in follow-up work using any of these
methods take a look at the bio bakery
site and I'd like to thank all of those
faces that you saw going by who the
people who actually did the work either
in the lab or several of our
collaborators much of this work was was
with from Xavier at the broad I
mentioned Owen and new markers group at
the University of Maryland wendy garrett
here at the School of Public Health and
then several former lab members such as
Nicola Sagada who has since gone on to
carry on a great deal of this work on
the earth their own so with that I'll
wrap up again think that the organizer
the audience and I think there's a
little time left for questions Curtis
this was a fantastic talk thank you so
much for sharing this with us this is
really I've got about 4,000 question
and in five minutes to ask them in um
but I wanted to just these are some
questions of my own and as somebody who
is not a microbiome assist this is
fascinating for me and when I back in
the olden days when I was learning about
genetics there was a real emphasis at
least kind of during the initial phases
of the the micro biological genomics
kind of explosion there was still a lot
of interest in doing population genetics
and looking at things like gene fitness
and as genes propagate through a
distribution and whatnot is there any
sort of in your opinion opportunities
for those old-school
population geneticist mathematicians to
take a look at some of these data and
look at gene frequencies in some of
these different populations and and what
happens to those genes as they spread
through populations and either are
beneficial or otherwise does that make
sense it makes sense it's a great
question and very timely one one of the
things I think has been exciting about
the past years worth of computational
biology in the microbiome is the ability
to see that kind of data at sufficient
resolution to do sort of classical
microbial genetics in a culture
independent or metagenomic way so some
of these strain identification methods
for example has only just recently
become precise enough to track strain
variation and divergence and population
genetics for every bug in a community at
the same time and we're starting to get
to the ten thousands of gut microbiome
samples available globally to do that
sort of tracking across multiple
populations simultaneously so yeah that
is yeah it's so exciting because you
know when you're talking about your
population genetics at least you know
the Cavalli sports and Bodmer type of
old-school population genetics you know
that was all like very theoretical right
lots of differential equations to try to
theoretically analyze what would happen
Jeane spread through a population to
fixation and hardy-weinberg equilibrium
xand so forth and so on but you actually
have the population of bugs to analyze
and watch what happens as a new gene
gets introduced into that population and
what happens to it and be able to watch
the behavior of the bugs watch their
biochemical output as a consequence of
as these genes spread through that
population what happens to them and is
that beneficial or not and I was also
thinking about something that you had
mentioned about the specificity of the
different bugs for their various niches
on the body where you have say you know
something that lives on the skin is not
necessarily the same population of bugs
which live inside the gut and I was also
curious about because it looked like you
were sort of talking about I don't know
if you touched on it in particular but
immune responses to when say something
it's even from an individual something
like bugs from their gut get introduced
accidentally into a different area of
the body so I was thinking in my head
like what happens when because you know
for those of us who've had kids what
happens when bugs from the gut get
introduced into the eye this is
basically pinkeye right so you basically
get gut bugs introduced into the
conjunctiva of the eye and you get an
immune response of swelling and pus and
all sorts of other nastiness and you
know there's a really dramatic and
obvious immune response can you imagine
being able to look at the role of the
immune system in all of this definitely
it's much more I should say when Wendy's
area of expertise and then mine but we
work with her and andronik on immune
interactions quite a bit in in the gut
the kind of example that you raise come
comes up in the context of gut barrier
leakiness and the degree to which again
in a sort of cyclical way post triggered
inflammation can allow microbial
penetration through through the gut and
then conversely microbial invasion can
trigger inflammation and sustain that
leaking
so that certainly is a factor in
inflammatory bowel disease systemically
there is this interest and we've worked
with folks like Dan Littman on
rheumatoid arthritis we're certainly
either leakiness or perturbation in the
gut or potentially circulation or
triggers from distal microbes like oral
microbes could play a factor in sort of
miss triggering the immune system
systemically and then having it target
things like like the synovium at joints
in rheumatoid arthritis it's really
fascinating and one final question is
can you give us a comment on microbial
transplantation and what sort of
horizons exist for that well it's a
great question and you know every
everyone likes to talk about transplants
at the at the end of a talk
I'll not exact so there's there's I I
would certainly put the fecal microbiome
transplants in one of the real
translational success stories about the
microbiome so for so far certainly for
Clostridium difficile there's been a lot
of great results in properly screened
and clinically controlled the
transplants being able to really
ameliorate recurrent c-diff and they're
starting to be more work in FM tees for
inflammatory bowel disease where the
ecology is harder to restore again we
don't necessarily know yet what the
right pushes to give back immunity to
get it back to stability within an
individual and there's a lot of
subjective subject variation so I think
some of the neatest work going on in
that space right now is in understanding
one what is the best push to give to say
an ulcerative colitis individual what's
the right group of microbes whether that
should come from an FM key or whether
you can make an artificial cocktail that
behaves like an FM t and then to how to
tailor that to each individual so that
no matter what their sort of current or
baseline microbiome is that push gets
them back to a healthy state and that's
where
things like against train tracking and
understanding the biochemistry or
functional profile of what these bugs
should be doing is it helpful well with
that I'd like to thank Curtis Sutton how
her from Harvard Medical School or
School of Public Health excuse me for
his fantastic talk I'm just so just
blown away about a still another several
thousand questions but we've run out of
time but Thank You Curtis that was
really fantastic and thanks to everyone
who joined us today for those who've
been asking this is being recorded and
will be available online here a little
later today so if you want to rewatch it
or share it with friends please by all
means do and once again let me thank you
for tuning in to the big data to
knowledge guide to the fundamentals of
data science please look forward to
future lectures that we'll be having
here in the coming weeks thanks again
have a great weekend everybody